I'm a big fan of the movie goon I mean I
know a lot of people are you know and
thank you did you you play you must have
played hockey no no I played baseball
basketball football my a lot of my
friends played hockey oh yeah because
the character's not supposed to really
have played hockey because you can see
in the movie I think he was supposed to
be a better skater though but I just
remember when I met with Jay I
lied hard I was like yeah I can skate
they're sure you just get like ah come
on grew up in Minnesota of course like
Escape oh my God we get up to to you
know two weeks before we're supposed to
start shooting the the movie and I think
it was just like a quiet understanding
of like oh I guess we're gonna have to
tweak the character a little bit